the common denominator between my video
interview being taken there and Andrew
Kaufman's interview being taken down the
thing they both said is there is no
evidence that's been scientifically
produced that coded 19 exists they're
reptiles and they're disguised as human
beings and they are able to move up in
power do you actually believe that
concept I'm not saying that anyone must
believe it I don't give a damn if they
believe it or not we've got 10,000 cars
lined up in San Antonio for food banks
not the time to talk about reptilians
but I thought I wanted it is happening
now I think they go together good let me
explain go together I'm gonna talk about
the corona in the news market or I'll go
and have a cup of tea I mean making mind
up my attorneys recommend that I not do
this interview for obvious reasons
there's so many underground bases in
America on that basis with drowning in
conspiracies you don't believe that
coronavirus doesn't exist though reduce
the scientific evidence that it does
that's the conspiracy you make of it
what you will
I know haven't happened who said that it
happened the world was not run by the
forces that we thought it was run by you
said you're the son of God and the world
will be ending that year you were 38
years old at that time this is a man
with a lot of credibility what he says
people listen to I don't care who he is
he shouldn't be telling people what they
can and cannot talk about
did you ever think you will make you
I said I'm suppose I could take sweet
victory I know this slice meant for me
yeah yeah why would you bet on Goliath
well we got that a V value K me given
values contagious this world of
entrepreneurs we can evaluate a haters
honey run homie look what I become I'm
the unborn
[Music]
so look the one thing we all know is all
of us one way or another our have an
element of conspiracy theorist whatever
you want to call it some of us think you
know when you wake up in the morning you
go check the fridge you wonder why
you're the ice cream is missing you know
we had a full cheesecake how come it's
not here maybe the kids wake up I got
three kids maybe the kids wake up in the
middle of the night and be walk
downstairs take the ice cream go
upstairs I think it's a conspiracy maybe
that's why we don't have the ice cream
anymore
some people believe Tupac is alive
millions millions believe Elvis is alive
some believe some people believe 9/11
was an inside job and some people
believe coronavirus is not a pandemic it
is a plan Demick but today my guest
takes it to a whole different level some
call him a conspiracy theorist some call
him a conspiracy researcher I'm sure
he's gonna correct me on that here in a
minute but he's written over 20 books
lectured 25 plus different countries
he's gone up on stage in the most
respectable platform spoken for 10 hours
and he's got a very big fan base and
he's got a very big opposition today
because of a recent interview he did
with prime roast that was taken down on
YouTube and many of you asked for him
many of you requested for him to come in
as a guest and today my guest David Icke
David thank you for being a guest on my
team a real pleasure thank you yeah I'm
a conspiracy researcher a conspiracy
theorist in conspiracy theory were
actually brought into the widespread use
in the modern world by the CIA in 1967
they put out a document you can still
find it on the Internet to the
mainstream media in America urging them
to refer to those that were questioning
the Kennedy assassination official story
to refer to them as conspiracy theorists
basically propagating a conspiracy
theory and all these years later you
have the mainstream media all over the
world coming out with this conspiracy
theorist it's just a conspiracy theory
with not a clue that the CIA was
responsible for putting that into
widespread use just a form of
discrediting people see when you think
about it if you look at the dictionary
definition of a conspiracy and you will
well know with your background
there are laws against conspiracy so
they don't exist well why have laws
against them but if you one look at the
dictionary definition of a conspiracy
it's just two or more people conspiring
to bring about a particular end often
illegal and on that basis we're drowning
in conspiracies but I'm not seeing
conspiracies everywhere this is the
point I'm seeing one conspiracy with
infinite numbers of masks of that same
conspiracy and so one of the things that
I'm chord is a dock connector because
that's what I do i connect dots which on
the surface don't appear to connect but
if you go into the deeper into the the
shadows if you like deeper into the web
they all connect and I'm sure we'll get
around that to that today so you know
before we get into that I have a little
bit more I want to know you a little bit
more if you don't mind I want to know
more about who David Icke was in high
school if you and I were in high school
together you're 15 years old 16 years
old we're friends we're classmates we
play sports I'm sure that had gotten
very well by the way yeah who was David
Icke who was David Icke in high school
well um I was born in a place for
Leicester in the English Midlands in
what we call in Britain a working-class
background which is just basically
another way of saying we had no money
and in my early years I just wanted to
be a professional soccer player that was
my focus throughout my my childhood and
as a series of you know strange
coincidences which have been the story
of my life they unfolded I became a
professional footballer but then at 21
er I finished with rheumatoid arthritis
very rare at that age and one of the
other things that I'd loved and been
being passionate about in my childhood
was journalism and I used to read papers
vociferous Lee even as a kid so I left
football and became a journalist star
newspapers then went into radio and then
I became a national TV presenter news
and sport mostly sport in the end with a
BBC and then I another series of amazing
coincidences you know we'll go into it
now I ended up as a national speaker of
national quote leader of the British
Green Party for a short time and so I
had a series of extraordinary if you
like paranormal experiences which put me
on the journey that I'm still on this
was thirty years ago and what started to
happen in my life in most extraordinary
way and is still going on is that purely
by the if you like the synchronicity of
life um I was coming across more and
more layers and layers and layers and
layers of information this is from about
1991 that though the world was not run
by the forces that we thought it was run
by and I started to put together through
the books more and more information doc
connected information about who did run
the world and to what to what end to
what outcome to what endgame and for a
long time of course people say ah
rubbish mate but as the years have
passed more and more that's been in my
books back in the 1990s he's being read
on the television news never more so
than current events by the way and so
more and more people have gone hold on a
minute this bloke said this would happen
this bloke said that would happen and my
books are packed with things that have
been proved correct now why is that not
because I've sat in a darkened room
pulling it from the ether but because
there is a an agenda for the world run
by what I call the cult which operates
in every country just has no borders and
if you can uncover this projected agenda
for the world you can predict the future
if nothing intervenes to stop the agenda
unfolding
and that's that's what what has been
happening or you know I've been
predicting the future and it's turned
out to be correct but only because I've
uncovered the projection and gender and
nothing yet has intervened to stop it
now if you go further back because this
is a long projected agenda for reasons
we could maybe get into you go back to
oldest huxley with brave new world
published in 1932 why was he so
incredibly accurate about current events
why was George Orwell in 1948 with his
1984 so unbelievably accurate um with
current events why is a guy that I've
quoted in my books a number of times a
guy called dr. Richard day a big
rockefeller family insider and he spoke
to a meeting of pediatricians in
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania in 1969 and
shopton by saying turn off recording
equipment don't take notes because I'm
gonna tell you how the world's gonna
change and no one knows why he did it
I'm glad he did because of the
information that he's allowed me to my
back system but what he said in 1969
which is only 20 years after almost 1984
is absolutely extraordinary
not just in theme but in detail this guy
said in 1969 he described the internet
which was supposedly created in the 80s
he said that one of the plans is we
gonna make boys and girls the same but
we are going to inoculate people with
diseases and so on and so forth and and
how and this is just totally in line
with the research I've got from all over
the world I've been to 60 countries
researching this he said um we're going
to take over um with a world government
dictating to the whole planet and the
idea that and and what current events
are leading us to it's so fast is what's
been in my books for decades what I call
the hunger games Society this is the
outcome that they want and what you know
the outcome you can see the journey know
the outcome you'll see
the journey don't know the outcome these
events that become clear when you know
the outcome are just random and
bewildering and what's happening so it's
to create what I call the Hunger Games
Society where you have if you think of a
pyramid at the top of the pyramid you've
got a tiny few people which we now have
a name for the 1% and if you look at how
a handful of people now have the same
wealth as the poorest half of the
population you can see the 1% ain't
kidding at the bottom this has been in
my books for decades by the way never
mind current events at the bottom of
this pyramid is pretty much the rest of
humanity in deprivation and this is the
word in dependency on the 1% because
they don't have independent income
amazing I'm saying this in current
events they spin my books for a long
long time and between the 1% and the
rest of the population pretty much um is
designed to be again as I've been saying
for decades a vicious police military
state to impose the will of the 1% of on
the population and to stop the
population rebelling against the 1% and
just to finish the point this pyramid
structure The Hunger Games society again
it's been saying it for so long
is designed to be run not by elected
politicians but by technocrats it's
called a technocracy which is defined as
a society run by bureaucrats experts
engineer scientists and not elected
people Silicon Valley getting more and
more control of world events witness
Bill Gates in relation to current events
is all part of this technocracy
unfolding and key to it is that this
society is run by artificial
intelligence and you've got people like
Ray Kurzweil another technocrat a
executive of Google who has openly said
that around the year 2030 a year that
comes up from so many different
directions in so many different areas of
subject though a 22:30
humans will start to be have their
brains connected to AI and in his in his
own words and I'm summarizing as weapons
that connections made more and more
thinking will be done by AI until human
thinking as we currently know it is
basically negligible now if you look at
that mate and then you look at the
consequences of current events then you
can see that that hunger games society
he's vastly closer now but it was only
weeks ago when this whole viruses theory
began David I want to go to that part
and spend majority of time talking about
that a couple things I do want to do
obviously I spoke to my attorneys my
attorneys recommend that I not do this
interview for obvious reasons and Janice
is there to say no especially McGarrett
said it is in my experience oh you don't
need to tell me that I mean I've had
plenty of fuse with attorneys and play
many times I've wasted money with
attorneys I wish if you can listen to
the conversations I've had with
attorneys that could be a whole episode
by itself but to manage expectations I
listen to your stuff and the way I work
with a lot of theories or conspiracies
or any of that stuff where somebody that
grew up in Iran and the Revolution I'm a
revolution baby and they didn't want to
talk about the influence of Jimmy Carter
with Iran Kissinger I don't need to go
into the whole thing you kind of have
the history of what happened in Iran and
CIA thirty years later comes out with
Oregon says yes this was kind of taking
place here's kind of what was going on
and they use the movie to tell us the
story so I'm not the one that says there
isn't some weight behind what's being
said but I'm also not the one that says
100 percent oh my gosh just makes sense
i watch a video I'm good I'm the one
that wants to go do research so to
manage expectation I want to I want to
share with everybody what are some
things you've said in the past and then
what are some things we're going to talk
about here today and I'd like to ask you
about some conspiracies and then we go
into 5g coronavirus and we can we can
talk about that as well okay
for the majority part of this entire
thing right now you know you've said a
lot of things that have come true and
you've said some things that haven't
come true for example this is what you
said that did come true you said in
January 1999 between 2000 and 2002 the
United States will suffer a major attack
on a large city 9/11 happened you said
that it happened that that gives some
credibility to say how could somebody
like you get something like that right
now at the same time you said the world
will end in 1997 and by the way you can
correct go through all of these also you
said on a show with Terry walk-in back
in April 29 1991 which father I believe
that's also your birthday April 29 I
don't know if you knew that was the day
of your birth
I did I didn't actually know you were on
him on April 29 was your birthday that
was a day of error by the way FYI and
and he had you there you had your
turquoise outfit I kind of like your
second outfit more with all black when
you were there on 2006 I believe but you
said because the challenge started off
with you're the son of God and the world
will be ending that year you were 38
years old at that time and I've I've
made some comments myself and I've
evolved and I've changed and I you know
got a lot more things that I have
improved in my views you've also talked
only about the I'm a Syrian so
Babylonian and Assyrian they're very
close to each other and so you've also
talked about the reptilian you know
leaders in the world where there's the
Clintons where there's - Obama's whether
it's all that other stuff and there's 12
million people that believe in that
theory so you're not alone in that one
there's four percent of America that
believes in that so to put all things
everything here we also have to know
that in the past you've said some stuff
that has thrown people off and some
stuff that have not become a reality I
just want to know that okay okay well
let me let me talk about that what
you're talking about is pre-1992
and since and since 1992 my books have
been phenomenally accurate this is why
vast numbers of people are looking at my
stuff now because I've been so accurate
year on year on year
with it with events but of course what
I'd been uncovering is the same
conspiracy the same agenda that oldest
Huxley was talking about and and all
well was talking about settling thing
and just a modern-day version of
uncovering it and uncovering it on a on
a greater scale so let's go back before
1992 and and let's just very quickly
look at what happened to me and why all
that woven stuff happened I um was a
journalist with a BBC I was a national
spokesman for the British Green Party
and then during 1989 I had a gathering
strange experience happened to me I'm
working for the BBC on national
spokesman for the Green Party but when I
was in a room alone it felt like I
wasn't alone like there was like a
presence there something I'd not
experienced before and through 1989 this
presence fought stronger and stronger
and stronger until I sat on on on a bed
in an empty hotel room in early 1990
actually March 1990 and I set out into
the room if there's something there
would you please contact me because
you're driving me up the bloody war and
a few days later I was I was in a new
shop sells newspapers and gifts and
tourist stuff and I long story short I
felt myself it was it was what were I I
know it was now is I was surrounded by
an electromagnetic field and it felt
really strange it felt like my feet were
hmm
bidding pulled magnetically to the
ground and what passed through my mind
it wasn't a voice it was a very strong
thought it said go and look at the books
on the far side now I knew this new shop
and I knew that the books were all
romantic novels not my scene give some
to the tourists I live at the seaside
place so I walk over a bewildered
thinking what done hell is going on and
I saw a book in among the novels and it
was a book called mind to mind by a lady
called Betty shine and I was attracted
to it because it was different the
others and I turned it over and in the
blurb I saw that this was a book almost
a biography by a professional psychic in
England which I had never heard of the
time called Betty shine so very quickly
I read the blurb and I thought a one day
she gonna ditch was suck it for me life
wondered if she would be able to pick up
what I'm feeling around me for the last
year so I went to see her and I you know
my football career finished with
arthritis and III what I told her was
because she did the hands-on healing
which is just an exchange of energy um I
told her at the ITO maybe her hands on
healing will help I didn't tell her
anything else because didn't want to you
know put anything into her mind and I
went there and I'm sitting on the bench
and she's hands on healing me me left
knee and I felt like a spider's web on
my face just like you know again what I
know now it was an electromagnetic field
and maybe my face tingle but I didn't
know that at the time oh it's all new to
me and i sat there felt this on my face
and I thought that's what she said in
her book but where other levels of
reality are trying to lock into you
sometimes feel like the spider's web or
new face said nothing to her 10 or 15
seconds later she launches her head back
and says my god this is powerful I'm
gonna have to close my eyes for this one
and she then starts to tell me huh I'm
just a bloke I work with a BBC mate I'm
just sitting there and she starts
telling me she's seeing a figure in her
mind and this this figure is wants to
communicate with and she said he's this
figure he's saying you're going to go
out in a world stage of reveal great
secrets you're gonna be world famous one
man cannot communicate
one man cannot basically saved the world
but but one man or changed the world but
one man can communicate the message that
can change the world that was one of the
things that came out and I'm sitting
there thinking what and it I was going
to be led to knowledge and at other
times knowledge would be put directly in
my mind
so I'm thinking all right yeah okay so I
I leave and my life immediately became
this extraordinary uhm synchronistic
journey of people documents books
personal experiences but were giving me
puzzle pieces almost in the order that
was easiest to see how they fitted and
this has gone on now for thirty years
now coming around to that whole Wogan
thing in this period I had this
overwhelming desire out of nowhere to go
to Peru what I've seen Peru play the
football World Cup a few times but Peru
well what are you feeling that a proof
or anyway I go purely on instinct purely
on intuition amazing things happen which
I cover in my books but anyway I end up
at a place called Cu Stanny which is an
inca site to just I don't know 20
minutes 25 minutes drive from puno on
Lake Titicaca the highest navigable lake
in the world they say I'm the reason I
went to to see you Stanley it's because
I'm a Peruvian guy who was going around
Peru with me um he booked us into this
hotel in puno called this see you
started this pictures of this place
although for the Burley hotel and when I
was looking at these pictures
something was saying go you must go you
must go so I organized her taxi bus to
go the next day and it was a beautiful
place um out with all Inca was said
sänger it's probably older sites Paula
on the hill and I walked around for
about an hour and it was lovely but
there was what at the urge I felt to go
there was not matched by the experience
so get back in the taxi taxi bustling
with the driver and the gun side and we
start driving back and no more than
three or four minutes down the road and
I'm kind of daydreaming out of the
vehicle you know and I was looking at
this hill and I'm looking as I'm looking
at it all I can hear in my mind he's
come to me come to me come to me
I know you like Mike I get you lost it
son that he was talking to yeah
what so anyway I just said to the people
can you stop that stop stop the vehicle
I'm going up that hill so I walk up not
knowing what the heck is going on and I
get up to the top but there's there's
these kind of stones there uh I walked
into the center of a group of them and
I'm standing on this hill in Peru under
a piercing cloudless sky a piercing Sun
I had a big red nose to prove it so I
walk into these this least area of
stones and suddenly it was exactly what
happened although you know a hundred
percent more that happened to me in the
news shop I started to feel this what I
would now call electromagnetic field I
didn't know about that then and I
started to feel my feet being pulled to
the ground like magnets and I started to
feel an energy going through me that way
and out that way at the top of my head
and into the top of my head through my
feet into the ground and then um I heard
this not voice but very strong
thoughtful matter aware it said one
they'll be talking about this in a
hundred years and two it will be over
when you feel the rain and understanding
that under under a cloudless sky it was
just ridiculous
but then my arms go out at 45 degrees
like that I made no conscious decision
to do that and this energy and they were
like that for a black must have been the
best part of an hour and I felt nothing
and said it was over and then my
shoulders of my arms and with agony but
anyway um this energy just built up and
built up and built up so in the end I'm
kind of shaking and you know when you
you drive a car and you can't remember
the last two miles or so because she's
subconscious has been driving the car
thank goodness what it was like that I
would I would have missing kind of
conscious time
and then I would come back to
consciousness while all this is going on
and I noticed that one of those points
where I became conscious again that over
in the distant mountains there was a
light gray mist and the light gray mist
became a dark gray mist and I thought
it's raining over those mountains and
you know if what then happened had
happened in a movie you would say that
is ludicrous who put this in the script
because what happened is these that this
rain storm came out of the mountains
towards me ridiculously quickly and in
the end I'm standing there like that
and this wall of stair rod rain I've
described it's like pulling curtains
across the sky was coming towards me by
the time it hit me you know I'm like
absolutely shaking with this energy soon
as it hit me absolutely soaked me in an
instant
um the energy stopped now my shoulders
are agony now my legs are like Bambi
trying to stand up and my life at that
time was transformed I tell you what it
was like and right in the middle of what
I'm going to describe is when the Wogan
show happened which is why I said things
that you know I look back now and you
know I wouldn't say now because I was in
the myths of a total transformation of
my consciousness my awareness my
perceptions I've described it like this
you're going along with your life and
life seems a certain way but you you're
operating within a bubble of perception
a bubble of information and then someone
comes along out of nowhere it doesn't
give you any warning and pops the bubble
now vast amounts of information concept
as things of all kinds are pouring into
your consciousness of a conscious mind
that weren't before and you're trying to
process them
and for three months I couldn't process
I mean right in the middle of that was
the woven show I've described it like
this you press too many keys on the
computer at once which is giving the
computer too much information to process
computer freezes that was me for three
months after three months after the
Wogan show and the mass historic levels
of ridicule that I went through in the
in the aftermath of that it was like the
computer unfroze now I'm now I'm David
Icke again if you like and people were
coming up to me and say David I thought
you'd gone mad you're the same bloke
I've always known I seemed it on the
surface but I wasn't because now I could
see things and how things connected that
I couldn't see before and so from that
point on the accuracy of my work if I
say it myself because it is true has
been phenomenal in terms of the way it's
played out in events including current
events before that which you rightly
bring up um I I was actually in this
this massive transition if you'd have
asked me my name in that period of three
months I would probably had to check
really if I would ask your name during
that three months you would have to
check well yeah that's a bit of an
exaggeration but you know if I'm saying
so you know then everything kind of came
into clarity massive clarity clarity
like I had never seen before and that's
what's played out ever since David when
you went to Peru at that time where you
are recreationally or were you just
yourself using any drugs man-made or
natural um no no none so are you
somebody that has experience with drugs
or no once one and that was in 2003 in
the Brazilian rainforest I was asked to
go and speak to a group who were taking
something called ayahuasca which is a
psychoactive ocean which is used as part
of some religions in in Brazil so I
thought yeah I'll go on and and do that
and I am I could have taken this stuff
and it's the only time I ever have
I've felt me before a since I took it to
nights over two nights could have taken
it four times what I got out of the two
nights was absolutely phenomenal
especially the second one um when you
take this stuff tastes a bit like a
licorice for about an hour you know it's
kind of metabolizing and then it hits
you and what happens is um when you
close your eyes you're in a completely
different state of awareness when you
open your eyes you are back in this
awareness the thing is your eyes don't
want to stay open and for five hours
this very powerful voice took a female a
form it's powerful and loud as mine is
now gave me chapter and verse on the
illusionary nature of what we call
physical reality how the physical is an
illusion and what this really is is a
holographic illusion of physicality and
so much else that I was told and it was
all about the nature of reality itself
and to understand world events you have
to understand the basics of reality
because this cult knows that it wants to
keep it from ours and the secret society
isn't listen tannic groups are there to
isolate that knowledge about reality in
their hands and to keep it from us so I
came back to Britain after that and I
started because I had amazing as it may
sound I had instant recall in the whole
five hours of information um and so I
came back in a starry erm investigating
mainstream science and all the different
disciplines to see if this stuff would
stand up and what I found was that much
of mainstream science not least sytem
quantum physics as all already knows
that physicality is an illusion but
because the different disciplines of
what we call mainstream science don't
talk to each other and indeed often
compete
in each other it means that the dots
have not been connected to show that
actually this absolutely stands up
what's happened since I started writing
about this in the early 2000s is that
more and more mainstream scientists are
starting to come out and say the same I
was writing that this reality is a
holographic digital holograms that's
what this physicality is and then you
have a guy like rich trill who's a
computer scientist at NASA and he came
out few years ago and said he'd
concluded that our reality isn't digital
hologram is what I've said years
exploring ebooks and what we're seeing
now is more and more mainstream
scientists who are coming out and saying
actually physicality is holographic and
this was given to me in this ayahuasca
experience back in what 2003 but apart
from that I've not taken any drugs don't
feel the need are you somebody that
believes in psychics and would you
consider yourself a pretty superstitious
guy no not at all that's all yeah all
this superstition and all this stuff
it's dead simple it's dead simple I just
explained out how reality works if you
said to people when you look through
your eyes can you see everything that
exists in the space you're looking at
what they're gonna say they're gonna say
yes but they can't what we call the
world is a ridiculously narrow band of
frequency called visible light and the
electromagnetic spectrum and according
to mainstream science the
electromagnetic spectrum and visible
light which is the only world reality
that we can see is a smear of the
electromagnetic spectrum mainstream
science says that that spectrum
nevermind visible light represents about
naught point naught naught 5% of what
exists in the universe and some say it's
a bit more but not much so we don't live
in a world we live in a
and of frequency which our body brain if
you like decoding system can decode into
a reality a holographic reality and
therefore infinity exists outside this
narrow band of frequency but we can't
see it just as when you're tuned to a
radio station or a television station
you only experience that frequency that
station that reality what happens when
you switch the zapper is you switch to a
different if you like frequency and you
get a different reality instantly we
call them different channels now these
different realities
operate in different bands of frequency
and just like radio frequencies etc
these bands of frequency as long as
they're not too close on on the dial to
each other when you get interference
they can share the same space without
being affecting all the others and each
one not even being aware that all the
others exist so we are we are basically
experiencing a holographic television
channel which we call the world and
outside of that are all the other
realities of infinite reality and only
when these realities get close on the
dial do you get interference and one of
those areas of interference if you like
is um is what we call ghosts and
paranormal things and such like when you
get two radio stations close on the dial
you get interference one is the dominant
one you can hear and the other one is
you can't hear it but you can you do
well but you can hear it it's
interfering well in a visual form that's
what a ghost is it is operating on a
level of frequency that's not spot-on
the one that we are experiencing thus it
doesn't look solid like it would if it
was on our frequency but it's
interfering enough that you can see it
especially if you
sensitive and this is a sensitive in
terms of frequencies so this is why
someone will stand in a room with
someone and they'll say this have ghost
over there and the other person will say
don't be a don't be a prat consti
anything big different sensitivities
now what psychics are doing and when we
talk about psychics the mediums you got
to make sure you've got a good one
because there's lots of people out there
claiming to be it aren't but you get a
good one I don't know the difference
they can they can expand their frequency
range that they can connect with beyond
the normal range of human frequency and
they can tap in to frequencies that are
outside of the normal human range and
you can pick up information from outside
there that's not available here and I've
um I've had experiences over the years
of phenomenal amounts of information
that you can pick up if you if you
expand your awareness beyond there the
tiny band of frequency that we have when
I started out after that be woken
experienced and under not really the
Wogan experience that's as part of it
the you know blow your mind experience
when I started out then uncovering
things what would happen is that I would
look at information received and then I
would come to conclusions very soon
after that as my consciousness expanded
and I'm not sitting there cross-legged
on a mountain like a girl you know under
guru my consciousness expanding anybody
can do it it's just that this cult don't
want us to do it and that's why we're
constantly pressured to perceive the
world only through the five senses which
means only through this narrow band the
frequency called visible light but what
happened then very soon is I would come
to conclusions about what was happening
and then the five cents name date people
information would follow that to confirm
that the conclusion was correct and
that's been going on now for decades and
that's that's that's how the books have
become so accurate that
that process fair enough so David a
couple things I like what you said you
said some of the things you said during
that three-month period you've changed
so son of God and the world's going to
be ending though that three-month period
that few months has your position also
change with the Reptoid hypothesis oh no
that hasn't this is the point mate that
I made earlier
um pre pre-1992 say pre mid-high need
anyone actually you go before that and
I'm in the middle of this transformation
on what I was talking about the the son
of God by the way what I was referring
to is that we are all aspects of one
infinite awareness that has not changed
one iota
we are points of attention within the
same infinite state of awareness and and
that individuality that we experience is
our individual point of attention but we
are all part of the same whole we're all
if you like droplets I'm in the same
ocean and we are the droplet and we are
the ocean so on that basis if you want
to use this symbolic language we're all
sons and daughters of the whole the
infinite whole so that has not changed
just putting in a different way that's
not changed at all and there was a group
remember Kunti
if you look pre 91 or pre mid 91 that's
one thing you look post Kareena mid 91
to present-day and you'll see a
completely different outcome in terms of
information that's proved to be correct
but but but to put it in to manage the
expectation series you did say even
Jesus was criticized so the comparison
wasn't just being a son of God at that
time you made the reference in a
complete different way just before yeah
yeah but you see the thing is that
um these concepts that pour into my
conscious mind which I'm trying to
process and understand you know you can
you can confuse son of God were all son
to God in that process and then
eventually it becomes clear what it
meant so you know it's it's it was a
period of great confusion as it as it
would be you know what I describe it
like this what was happening in my mind
in that period um
19 early ninety-one until about till
about April April know about May sorry
yet never May 91 at January 91 February
91 when I went to Peru
so about May 91 that was the period that
all that took place and and it's like if
you if you burst a dam and that's what
happened you know my consciousness
opened up to another level and you burst
a dam and the water cascades out and
it's going all over the place and then
it finds balance in the new situation
and that that's the process that I was
going through for about three months but
let's not forget before we do that that
was the best part of 30 years ago and in
the intervening period since then the
accuracy of my books in predicting
current events has been well I mean what
why a vast numbers of people looking at
my work now because of that but David so
again last time so anything position
change on the Reptoid hypothesis
anything on that seat or it's the same
belief that you had been there you have
to be yeah that didn't that didn't come
in that pre 91 P to come up with that
conclusion where he said this is in the
Sheep hole and all of that how did that
process and come about quite simply the
same process that everything else came
about
synchronicity of my life led me to the
information so I'm minding my own
business traveling around America
talking to next to nobody at the time in
I don't know towards the late 90s what
would it be maybe 96 that kind of period
96 97 more 96 and I'm going from place
to place
talking each night some of them were
long way apart and in a period of 15
days I met 12 different people in 12
different places who told me the same
stories about this old reptilian
phenomena I'll go into it now at length
it's all in my books in the enormous
detail and so if you are a proper
journalist and you're after the truth
and not a statue in a round of applause
then you look at that and you said hold
on a minute this is a lot of people
telling me the same thing and this is
this is what my life has been like since
that mind-blowing experience this is
just how it is
synchronicity a new subject will come
into my life and suddenly information on
its coming from all angles wherever I go
and then you you start to expand this
you get more and more information and I
have this process when I'm when I'm
researching them of what I call the back
burner so when something comes up and
when this on reptilian thing comes up I
mean you know you don't just say all
right
it's you reptilians because this lady
told me you don't do that you put it on
the back burner and you see if more
information is going to come and more
information is going to come and it did
over and over over years for instance a
man who's only just that died actually
at the age of 98
a man in South Africa he was a high Zulu
shaman and the official historian of the
Zulu Nation mental crater with what and
I met him and and he didn't know
anything about what
I was writing about and he started
talking about something called the
Chitauri as was the [ __ ] hurry and he
told me all the stories and legends of
Zulu lore about a reptilian race that's
manipulating human society outside of
human visual acuity for reasons i've
explained and then i you start looking
at some other cultures other belief
systems other legends in various
different cultures and you start to
realize there is a massive common theme
among all of them and that is what do
you call it reptilian or not don't
really matter there is a common theme
which is there is a force which outside
human sight is not human which is
manipulating human society via a network
within human society and if you go into
the inner in the core of the most
exclusive secret societies why they
secret societies to keep secrets from
the rest of the population you find that
this non-human force is actually what
these people are worshipping you go back
a long period and you see the ancients
were worshipping their gods and people
say oh yeah well they were they were
just ancient and primitive
this cult is doing the same now and
they're the same gods so if you look at
Christianity there it talks about the
the demons it talks about the Fallen
Angels you look at the Zulu culture they
talk about the chitter Hui you look at
the Gnostic belief system they talk
about the archons in in Islam they have
the concept of the jinn um and and
wherever you go I talk to people from
Aboriginal culture in in Australia they
have the same belief that there's a
nonhuman force manipulating human
society so you have this common common
theme and it's something that is
becoming a
more and more perceived by more and more
people because it starts to make sense
of the world and where the world's being
taken so this is where it all can it
comes from and people say well why don't
we see him well why can't you see other
realities outside of visible light
because that's where these this force
operates from and what it needs is a
force within this visible light
frequency through which it can
manipulate human society and that's this
this cult and all these this network of
secret societies and which are
manipulating world events I don't think
there's any question that these secret
societies exist and we're gonna talk
about that but now you actually believe
reptiles are disguised they can disguise
as human beings like do you really
believe that concept because we know
there's powerful people but the concept
of their reptiles and they're disguised
as human beings and they're able to move
up and power do you actually believe
that concept well you see I mentioned
earlier that to understand what is going
on we have to have some understanding of
the nature of reality because if we
don't we will quite understandably
dismiss things that are happening but we
can't perceive how they could happen
example you believe the world is
actually solid our bodies are solid that
wall is solid and not a holographic
illusory physical then if the world is
solid then people moving between
different if you like shapes what they
call shape-shifting is impossible
utterly impossible course it is you
can't you can't shape-shift solidity is
ridiculous but if you believe the world
is solid immediately you hear some of
the things that I say um they're
immediately dismissed not possible well
hold on if you look at computers and the
illogical Wi-Fi world we live in now
what you're looking at is a
technological reality that mimics real
reality our experience reality and how
we create it so you've got a are a Wi-Fi
field okay
where is it where's the wife by Phil
point it out to me well I can't because
you can't see it right now if you didn't
know about computers and I said to you
there is a field of information that
we're living in like a sea people would
say well where is it I can't see it
therefore it can't exist but because
people know about computers you um you
say you know there's a field of
information and you can decode oh yeah
yeah I know about that Wi-Fi that's
right and the only difference between
that's rubbish mate and oh yeah I know
about that is knowledge knowledge of
what you are experiencing and what
you're talking about in terms of reality
so what does the computer do you've got
a Wi-Fi field full of information in the
form of radiation basically and the
computer decodes it onto the screen and
you say to people and and it's coated on
the screen by the way on the basis of
the information you put in to decode
onto the screen what you choose to
decode you say to people tell me about
the internet and they say oh yeah what
it's pictures and graphics and text and
all that stuff and websites yes it is
but only on the screen on the screen is
the only place the internet exists in
that form everywhere else it's
electronic codes and Wi-Fi we decode
reality in exactly the same way the five
stanzas take waveform information think
Wi-Fi turn
into electrical information feeds it to
the brain and there are different parts
of the brain that specialize in decoding
the different senses and the brain
decodes that electrical information into
holographic digital information and that
is what we experience as the world
around us it's not around us it's inside
us all of us just as the Internet is
inside this computer and we look at it
from afar so say you're tasting
something you don't taste it with the
tongue you taste it via the tongue which
sends electrical information
representing the taste frequency to the
brain which decodes it and then it
becomes yummy or that's horrible there
are now pain relief techniques used in
hospitals where they stop the message
going from the point of pain to the
brain because if they stop them that the
brain cannot decode the message and you
can't feel pain take the hearing senses
what's passing between ours and what
passes between all of us when we're
communicating are not words they're wave
filled frequency fields generated by the
vocal cords and these are picked up by
the ears that turn them into electrical
information feed it to the brain and
only when the brain decodes it - you
hear words I'll give you an example does
a falling tree make a noise well only if
you hear it and what I mean by that is
if it's tree falls what it's doing it's
an electromagnetic field and it is
causing a disturbance in the wider
electromagnetic field as it moves if
there's no one there to decode that D
disturbance then a falling tree doesn't
make a noise if there is someone there
they pick up that disturbance with the
ears that let your magnetic disturbance
and they decode it into the sound of a
tree falling it's all an illusion and
this is what they don't
just to know because they know it is and
they're manipulating the illusion to
control human beings but to do that
they've got to keep from from us that it
is an illusion so why all the world
events stuff that I have exposed over
the years has always been alongside the
nature of reality stuff so the human
body is a field of information and we
are decoding these fields think a Wi-Fi
field think of the body as a Wi-Fi field
of information we decode the body into
holographic reality the body actually
only exists in our in our decoded senses
in the form that we spit in its other
form it's an electromagnetic field of
information so it's not solid it's
holographic and it's malleable so I'm
looking at someone and they have a human
electromagnetic field of information so
what I'm decoding into holographic
reality in my head is a human being
these um cult bloodlines that I expose
have a dual field a hybrid field these
are what we're talking about here
they're the biblical Nephilim that's
what we're talking about the sons of God
Oh interbred with the daughters of men
you know that's what we're talking about
but the Bible calls the Nephilim so
there is a dominant field in the jewel
field say it's human it is most of the
time stop I will look at someone if
anyone looks at them and they decode the
human field and what did this is a human
but when there's a shift from the human
field to the non-human field the
observer then starts um decoding the
nonhuman field and to the observer who
can see apparent solidity someone has
moved from a solid body of human to a
solid body that's not human and back
again but that's not what's happened
because there is no solidity its
decoding into a holographic form
decoding into another holographic form
decoding into the original holographic
form and this is what we call
shape-shifting and if but if you don't
know that then of course you're going to
dismiss the very idea is in part
well if you think the world is solid
it's not the cult knows it he doesn't
want us to know never personally
witnessed any sense of them I've seen
ice change yes I've seen ice change to
reptilian yes but the point is that I'm
not a kamikaze pilots I'm just
interested in the truth and I will
pursue the truth no matter what really
killed of stuff I mean meaningless to me
truth so but I have talked to so many
people all around the world of
experience this you then go back and you
look at historical records and and
cultural records and they're describing
the same phenomenon what what is your
your your format like for me I was a
stockbroker
so you know what it is when you're like
you cannot make any kind of predictions
I guarantee this thing can give you 24
percent the war guarantee cannot be used
as a financial advisor etc etc you know
what is your form of looking at
something and saying shape shifting has
to have happened even though I've never
witnessed that I saw ice shifting but
I've never seen it do you your brain I'm
just curious on how you process it do
you go to say I give it 70% credibility
that it exists I give it 20% or do you
say no shape-shifting 100% and if yes
based on what one 100% pending after 30
years of accumulating the information
you've never seen I have seen eyes
change from human to reptilian that's a
shape-shift and I talked to endless
people in every other culture now here's
the point look at the information water
am I not saying here what am I not
saying I'm not saying that anyone must
believe it I don't give a damn if they
believe it or not that's their right
that's their choice that's their
uniqueness what I'm saying is here is a
vast body of information that I put
together and vast man they might earlier
books on this subject make of it what
you will
that's what I'm saying I must say you
gotta believe it I know that has to be
your choice based on what you make of
the information that's all it is it's a
very persuasive
thing to say because you know when you
say I'm not saying you have to believe
it that is a form of getting me to want
to believe it more because it's not be
enforce its by choice I got to tell you
David you're one of the best
storytellers I've met in my life
you're an incredible storyteller with
the details I mean I was in Peru with
you just so you know that I was in that
cabin I saw the mountain I was there
with you I don't know a lot of people
that tell stories as good as you do and
I'm in the world of storytelling
have you ever read the story that was
published in the weird times of August
of 1929 called the shadow kingdom you
ever read that story no you've never
read it now you ever seen the movie of
five million years to earth a 50s movie
you've never seen it no okay
okay interesting okay that's good so
let's set that part aside so let's go
away from our reptilian shape-shifting
girlfriends and let's go to the next
topic maybe it wouldn't mind if I give
you a conspiracy theory and in less than
five seconds you say there is some truth
to it there is no truth or I don't care
like I don't it's not something I'm
interested in is that fair with you
that's fair let's just play a game here
okay here we go
Tupac is still alive chicken Tupac is
still alive I don't get it that's okay
he's a rapper so that means you don't
buy a yo Elvis is still alive I doubt it
okay y'all matter to me JFK
assassination was an inside job 100%
alright next Obama party is it in the
for it by a bullet shot from behind him
what did it do you turns Obama birther
there Trump presented saying Obama
wasn't born in u.s. he was born in Kenya
absolutely open to that that's correct
but again that's that's that story and
I've left that behind Flat Earth theory
the earth is holographic and if you make
if you look at Holograms that we buy in
the shops how are they made they're made
by creating a flat interference pattern
of
literally frequencies on a on a print
and then those frequencies which
represent the object being photographed
are then hit by a laser which turns that
flat frequency interference pattern
representation of the object it turns it
into the object in three dimensions
right so because the world is
holographic the foundation of everything
is kind of flat but in its holographic
estate it's absolutely not flat so I
don't believe the earth is flat in the
way that we experience it at all but
like all Holograms
they are projections from a flat surface
and what we're seeing in science now is
more more and more scientists coming out
and saying they do believe that the
basis of the universe is actually flat
and and it becomes a holographic
three-dimensional representation well
that's exactly what I've been saying for
years how about the Bigfoot there's a
lot of Bigfoot sightings in Washington
state um there's a lot of things in the
world that we don't know about and that
could be one of them it could not but
you know in the end what you're looking
at is data what I mean by that is not
theories you're looking at data so if
you meet one person and they say I'll
see the Bigfoot oh okay that's
interesting but it goes no further but
when you got a hundred people or
whatever seeing our Bigfoot as they
claimed in the same area now you've got
the data there's a bloody good chance
something's going on here so let's say
you work next one it's gonna get better
by the way next one extra Denver
International Airport when two billion
dollars over budget
rumor has it illuminati build an
underground headquarters there i would
say that was 100% when I when I came to
accurate yeah when I came into America
for the first time to talk on these
subjects it was 1997 something like that
no 96
the first Airport I flew into to get off
the plane was Denver and I went to a
conference in Denver where some of the
people were talking about Denver Airport
that was their specialization and I
found Denver Airport a very weird place
with its gargoyles and it's free Masonic
presentations and stuff that you get and
these weird
wellhe murals of horrible things what's
that doing in an airport so I do think
that there's something underneath Denver
Airport is a lot of you know there's so
many underground bases in America what
they called um deep underground military
bases places the scattered all over
America these things and that's where
the real deal goes on and the technology
that he's developed there is vastly
ahead whatever we see in the public
arena volcano Yellowstone Wyoming that
if it erupts it could wipe out the
entire US no I did okay no idea uh UFO
do aliens exist 100 percent look at the
night sky look at the night sky what are
you having - laughs oh no you know you
know that compared with the perceived
size size of the universe planet Earth
is the equivalent of a billionth of a
pin it right yeah that sounds good to me
do we're on a billion Philip in it and
life as we know it only exists there
elsewhere oh no no you're mad of course
it exists it's just a case of what is it
whether it's benevolent or malevolent
and it'll be a mixture of all of them
and the idea that we're alone it is well
I mean they call me mad you know its
military and the government
experimenting and researching aliens at
area 51 well not just area 51 in general
and what's happened in the last what six
seven eight months is it's been
appearing on things like the Tucker
Carson show on Fox
I think Tucker Carlson I can't stand Fox
by the way constant CNN across town
MSNBC
are any of us down at the BBC but um as
a journalist who's willing to ask
questions the others aren't and make
points the others aren't
and then got a lot of respect for Tucker
Carlson and he's had people on his show
talking about the fact that the and Ava
had to admit it but the Pentagon has
radar pictures taken by its pilots of
craft that are doing things that no
technology that we know in the human the
visual arena could possibly do and of
course it's all classified and stuff so
they this there's two levels of
knowledge you see this cult operates
folks just explain this it might make a
lot of sense to people not least of
current events the world is manipulated
by a web and think of a where the
spider's web and at the center of the
web you got the spider that spider is
the nonhuman force around the spider in
the strands immediately around the
spider are the most exclusive secret
societies and people in them you
probably never heard of they're the
people really running this cult from the
inner inner sanctum as you come out from
the spider in the web you're now
starting to hit the secret societies we
do know about what we don't know what
goes on there they'd like us not to like
the Freemasons anammox walk in the inner
core and the Knights of Malta the
Knights Templar the inner core of the
Jesuit Order all this stuff and as you
come out eventually you meet what I call
the cusp organizations would sit between
the hidden and the seen but these are
the Council on Foreign Relations in
America the trilateral commission
created by the Rockefellers and Sevigny
Brzezinski Jimmy Carter's former
national security adviser and the
Bilderberg Group created in Europe at
the Bilderberg Hotel these are cusp
organizations that sit between the
hidden and the scene
and what happens is the agenda for the
world comes out from the spider through
the hidden through the cusp or
and into the society that the arena that
we see the public arena I'm there we
find government's government agencies
the banking system or the Silicon Valley
corporations and so on media ownership
and in this level of the public arena
it seems to be a series of completely
unconnected organizations agencies
whatever if you go deep enough into them
and it's all compartmentalized most
people in these organizations haven't
got a clue what they're being controlled
and directed to and what the agenda is
they just get on with their lives get
their pay and go home to their families
but at the inner core of these
organizations they are actually
answering to the spider ultimately and
are making decisions that reflect that
agenda of the spider and in this way
things are happening in a coordinated
way that appear to be random and this
can be seen very clearly in my
experience with the the Brian Rose
London real interview about the corona
virus which was streamed live and
YouTube took it down the moment
virtually the moment just a few minutes
after it finished but then you then
Vimeo took it down and then Facebook
took it down um it's because if you go
deep enough into these organizations
they are controlled by the same force
therefore move as one unit so LinkedIn
then trashed and deleted Brian roses
have count for doing that interview as
LinkedIn will ultimately go deep enough
be controlled by the same force that
controls all the others this is how how
how it works and so the each country and
it can be explained very simply this way
the way Lascaux operates and manipulates
globally and could coordinate this
coronavirus thing that we're looking at
now current events is the same as
McDonald's really McDonald's work or any
other transnational corporation I'm just
picking the dolls out here they have a
headquarters say in America and in each
country they have their subsidiaries and
the sub
the jerries operate in line and to the
blueprint of the headquarters and in the
same way that skull has a central point
and it has its sub operation networks in
each country and their job is to
manipulate that country's politics
business banking media in line with the
central irritated agenda and that's why
as this virus hysteria came out of China
basically all countries have reacted the
same because they're working to the same
script and this is this is how the whole
thing works okay so here's the next one
here on kiss on what if you've done any
kind of research on this one in Alaska
they have a high year frequency active
auroral research program you know this
looks like probably know where this is
going antennas that are experimenting
with weapons to be able to control
people's minds Oh 100% I've done
enormous research on this and and the
one in Alaska which is the famous or
infamous one which came to public light
there are others like that around the
world now and what they do is they fire
a frequency in today on ionosphere and
they make the ionosphere in the upper
atmosphere the vibrate in sympathy with
that frequency and then it diverts the
frequency now because of the vibration
at a far higher power that it left the
facility back to earth and many things
can be done with this including
manipulating the weather and creating
weather extremes among many other things
and again to come back to the nature of
reality is to understand how these
things work why fight G is so
destructive why Wi-Fi is so destructive
and so capable of transmitting thoughts
and perceptions into the human mind
because what what what are these
technologically generated
electromagnetic fields their frequencies
their electromagnetic frequencies the
brain processes in
Meishan electrically what a neurons do
they make electrical connections the
brain transmits to the rest of the body
the cellular structure of the body
electrically and electromagnetically so
um anything external that interferes
with the balance of that electromagnetic
communication in the body and the
processing of information electrically
in the brain is going to affect people
negatively psychologically and in terms
of health and we are now living in an
absolute sea soup of technologically
generated electromagnetic frequencies
which have gone on to a phenomenal new
level with this rollout this year still
going on um of 5g Elon Musk don't start
me by the way I'd love to debate this
guideline if you could ever arrange it
he's putting our satellites at low
altitude is happening all the time
every week to fire 5g at the earth so
there's no way you can get away from it
even if you want to go and live in a
forest and there's a reason for this I
explained it in the books why they doing
it
astronomers are now complaining even
with a relatively few of the thousands
he wants up they was 42,000 up there
he's already got permission from the
cult owned Federal Communications
Commission for tens of thousands he
wants 42,000 even with the few that he's
put up so far astronomers are saying we
can't see the night sky anymore it's
it's all mussed satellites and there's a
company called least one wave out of
britain doing the same there's others
doing the same now here's a question how
many people among the nearly eight
billion getting on for eight billion
people on planet Earth
I've been asked if they want that nobody
or being given a vote to decide if
they're who want that nobody must just
does it because musk is an asset like
gate
and all the others of this agenda that's
why he gets permission for the FCC of
course if the FCC is controlled by the
same force that controls Musk
he's gonna get permission for what he
wants cause he is and that sees that
this is how it happens so the challenge
with when I did the research on why you
took YouTube chose to take the video
down I don't know why Lincoln did what
they did by the way that that whole that
scandal makes no sense to me but I don't
know their reasoning behind it but I do
know why YouTube and Facebook and Vimeo
did YouTube says linking 5 G to
coronavirus was the biggest challenge
and I'd like to kind of transition now
we can go now all 5 G coronavirus let's
talk about those topics now since you
brought up
Elon Musk but we got a lot of weed now
none of you kind of has an idea where
you stand with different conspiracy
theories that people may have and they
can judge for themselves what we can go
from you I just want to make sure the
viewer knows that before we go to the
next part the challenge that YouTube had
with the interview that you did with
Brian Rose is saying that 5g is the
reason for coronavirus and I want to say
this to you I had a guest on General
Spalding from the Air Force okay Robert
Spaulding he wrote a book called stealth
war he is not a fan of China he went and
lived in China with his wife and kids to
learn about their culture how it's done
almost like an inside job to report back
to us and then years later he found out
what they were all about won back again
then eventually he was hired to work
directly with the White House as a
adviser as a director and one time he
gave a briefing on what China was really
doing and that got Mitch McConnell upset
and Biden up said now you know both of
them have a link to China by Melissa Don
and then you got Mitch McConnell and his
wife his wife's father owns the largest
construction company in China so one is
the Republican one's a Democrat so
Robert Spaulding is not somebody that is
a conspiracy researcher nor is he a
pushover nor is he somebody that boughs
down to the people
power this is a very reasonable man when
he says what he says he has no motives
behind it I called him we spoke a few
days ago I said hey general Spaulding
I'm hearing a lot of stuff that's being
said that there is a 5g is the reason
why corona virus is spreading and I kind
of gave him the timeline I said what do
you think about the fact that in 1916
the emergence of radio waves 1918
Spanish flu outbreak you know 2003 3G
was introduced to the world 2003 SARS
outbreak 2009 4G was introduced to the
world 2009 swine flu swine flu and now
2009 2025 G's introduced to the world
2019 2020 corona virus and I said how
much credibility do you give to this
this is a man with a lot of credibility
what he says people listen to he said
zero that's a conspiracy theory it has
nothing to do with that and those who
are talking about it shouldn't be
talking about it now that's one part I'm
gonna turn it let me let me just make
this one point very quickly I don't care
who he is
he shouldn't be telling people what they
can and cannot talk about known as they
cannot talk about it's not what he said
I said secondly I'm saying that the cat
the so-called corona virus is um can be
put down to two Phi G I'm saying it's
it's it's something that's be taken into
the mix for reasons we'll come to that's
a big difference there's a big
difference between saying that because
you know this on Guardian where dr.
Cohen got up and Cowen CO and claiming
5g wireless networks are behind the
pandemic this is not Guardian this is a
complete different man that got up and
he was presenting yeah and it was shared
by Keri Hilson you've seen this before
it's not IM not the first time i'm
telling you this it's michael gove or
gov who said that cousins here is a
greater brittany is threatened it goes
you needn't mind yeah so so again that's
that part to say that that's the part
that's getting people to be a little bit
where they're now tearing down the
towers and you never want to use a
form like this to get people to take
measures to different levels where
people are getting hurt and they're
breaking laws and I fully understand
that part my question was when you
submit it what is the credibility what
does your credibility come to say some
like that where the viewer can say this
makes sense credibility right well um
let me just tell you tell your story the
London real interview which was two and
a half hours long and I covered enormous
amount of it in five G of things and Phi
G was a relatively small part of it was
taken down and the idea was he was taken
down because I said five gh we bring
brought into the mix of current events
then my son Jaime did an interview with
an American doctor called Andrew Kaufman
operates out of New York State who's
done a tremendous amount of research
into this whole coronavirus situation
and they had a chat and YouTube took it
down after he got 300,000 hits they
didn't mention by gee the common
denominator between my video interview
being taken there and Andrew Kaufman's
interview being taken down the thing
they both said is there is no evidence
that's been scientifically produced that
kovat 19 exists that is what they want
to shut down even more than the 5g
connection you don't believe that though
you don't believe that Krone of ours
doesn't exist though of course well I'll
just say to you fruit produce the
scientific evidence that it does what
I'd been doing because I'm a journalist
not a mainstream media repeater of the
official story is I've been devouring
information from doctors biologists
specialists in places like Germany Italy
or
stria America who will never be allowed
to get onto the mainstream media course
they're challenging and demolishing the
official narrative that's not allowed
because this is not about a free open
debate it's about selling a lie they
tell you a story that comes from these
laurels
and in this case then as the way I'm
started from the research of them Andrew
Kaufman a doctor of medicine who's now
operates and specialized in psychiatry
in New York State when people started
getting ill in China the Chinese
authorities and by the way China is an
absolute major global center of this
cult as is America Israel Britain but
China's massive this cult his note has
no borders it operates across borders so
what they did is they decided pretty
much immediately but the reason people
were getting ill and they only did you
know checked and tested a tiny number of
the first like nearly two hundred the
goryeo that it was a bacteria or a virus
and they very quickly settled on a virus
and what they did and you know a virus
is not what we told it is either anyway
they took fluid from the lungs of a
small number of these people that got
ill and they broke down its genetic code
the genetic code of genetic material was
in the law and they decided that the
cause of the problem was a virus the
problem is they never and it has never
been isolated to show that that's what
is causing this there was a man in 1890
he was a a bacteriologist and physician
called Robert Koch and he developed for
what we came down as Koch postulates
which have been the gold standard for
mainstream medicine ever since of how
you prove that an
agent is causing a disease number one
all the people who get the disease after
have the same symptoms number two you
have to isolate what you say is the
causing agent from all other genetic
material so there's no contamination
you've only got what you say is causing
it you then inject this into a living
host
and the living host has to get the
disease you say this stuff is causing
and then you have to take material from
that living host put it into another
living host and they have to get the
same disease at that point with the code
postulates you've got pretty damning
evidence that that is causing that none
of those things not one of those
postulates has been done in relation to
Kabat 19 what they've got is a genetic
material from the lungs of those people
and that genetic material contains a lot
of stuff but it's actually in vast
numbers of people stop causing the milne
it's not making them sick but it's part
of their genetic makeup and if you test
for the genetic material not Coby 19e
they've never isolated it then you're
gonna get a lot of positive tests not
for some virus but for genetic material
that's in that code that vast numbers of
people have so what did they do then the
Chinese then started deciding who had
the virus they decided without isolating
it and proving it and who didn't and so
they did this first of all on symptoms
and what are the symptoms of coronavirus
a flu-like symptoms yes
which have a potential large range of
causes not now now if you had flu-like
symptoms in China in that period you had
corona virus and you had to be isolated
those is locked er they then start
testing so let's look at the test
the tests they're using for coronavirus
they're not they've never isolated it
they're testing for this genetic
material this test is called the rt-pcr
test was invented by a man called Kary
Mullis in 1984 and he said this test
should not be used to diagnose
infectious disease the man who invented
the test and what are they doing
they're saying we are testing for an
infectious disease the other thing the
test can't do openly admitted it can't
test how much a quote virus you have and
as one american medical scientist said
in a statement that i have them the
website you have to have in his words
massive amounts of this stuff to be sick
but the test can't say how much you have
so it's irrelevant they then start
moving out and they prepare us for it oh
yes all that Chinese virus it's coming
oh yeah and it starts to move out now I
know this from many many different
sources and some of them quite a number
of them now more and more other time in
America and in Britain and other places
have gone public on this from the
medical profession they were told that
flu-like symptoms must now be designated
diagnosed coded 19 and as I say flu-like
symptoms can come from a long list of
possible causes including the flu at
which there's a lot around this time of
year so they start diagnosing um Kovach
19 cases on symptoms and the numbers
start to go up all sale could be a
pandemic eventually the World Health
Organization which is owned by Bill
Gates the second biggest funder only to
the United States government of the
World Health Organization mr. vaccine
must have vaccine the world.the the
frontman for the World Health
Organization guy called Ted Ross in
other words some Casey's mouthpiece he
says yes it's a
endemic ok so then they start
introducing this test this PCR test and
they start testing but they're not
testing for Kobe 19 it's never been
isolated they're testing for the genetic
material and lots of people have it so
lots of people test positive problem is
but while they're doing this they don't
have enough dead people so they can't
produce the fact that this is a deadly
virus from the number of people who are
dying so what has happened and I'll give
you I'll give you an amazing piece of
supporting evidence here in a sec um the
medical profession were told by the
hierarchy think cult subdivisions in
each country that um if someone tests
this is happening all over by the way
country after country if someone tests
positive for Kobe 19 and any one metal
goes in a hospital or is treated you
fall down the bloody stairs and go to
hospital they test you for Kobe 19 the
genetic material not Kobe 19 they've
never isolated if someone has tested
positive for Kobe 19 then if they die
then they have to ask to go on death
certificate Kovach 19 and so you having
people and loved ones and families have
complained about this as well as some
doctors some doctors have come out so
we've been told to put Kobe 19 on the
death certificate when they haven't died
from it some loved ones have said that
you know their loved one died of cancer
but Kobe 19 went on the death
certificate and if you notice this is a
common theme you see it in the media all
the time the same phrase you see it from
politicians same phrase and these
medical advisers are all connected to
gates by the way yours in America around
Trump and ours in written around
Boris Johnson the phrase is this number
of people have died um or this person
has died after testing positive for
kovat 19 not died of it tested positive
for kovin 19 but then they go on the
death certificate and they become then
in the official figures died
Cobin 19 now if you look at the massive
health crisis in Italy it was based in
Lombardi Lombardi in northern Italy is
infamous for having diabolical polluted
air just like China and ruin well
therefore they have enormous amounts of
lung disease there and I'll tell you how
bad it is for your health in Lombardi
this is the Milan's in Lombardi they the
last the last figures I saw for a year
is that a few hundred less than 100,000
people died in Lombardi in that year and
the next region down for most deaths was
Lazio 57,000 that's how bad Lombardi's
so you have all this lung disease in
pneumonia and they've been redesignating
ATCO mid-nineteen when they were going
to die from it anyway from another cause
and the figures go up and the feeders go
up and the figures go up and I want to
read you this story America this is a
guy who is a state senator in Minnesota
called doctor he's doctor himself Scott
Jenson and he was interviewed on Fox
News and he said this right now Medicare
has determined that if you have a CO vid
19 admission to the hospital you'll get
paid $13,000 and a lot of this is some
of this anyway is um passed on to the
doctor if that Kovac 19 patient goes on
a ventilator the hospital gets 39
thousand dollars if they diagnose a
pneumonia patient as nan Kovac 19 they
get $4,600 and so there is a financial
incentive which if you add it all up is
absolutely fantastic to keep putting Co
vid 19 on the death certificate
over and above the instruction from
organizations like the CDC the Centers
for Disease Control and Prevention that
you should if if you suspected anyway
that there's Kobe 19 involved though you
can't say how much of it even if it
existed because the tests won't tell you
that you put Kobe 19 on the death
certificate
so these death numbers are absolutely
ridiculous unsustainable and
unsupportive all but what have they done
think of the Hunger Games society I
mentioned earlier that structure they
have destroyed the independent
livelihood through this lockdown or
billions of people destroyed businesses
destroyed employment lots of people are
going to lose their homes their banks
owned by the cult are going to start as
soon as they can
repossessing because people can't pay
that mortgage and anymore and it's going
to be it is already economic mayhem with
this is absolutely the Hunger Games
society long bread lines form outside of
food banks as America struggles to cope
with Kobe 19 fallout at least 10,000
cars line up in an orderly fashion in
San Antonio all full of hungry
increasingly desperate people thousands
already arrived the night before just to
get the chance to eat we just can't feed
this many the CEO of the local food bank
sir said about Texans that had descended
upon the place it's a scene playing out
across the country 1,300 cars
swamped the drive through Greater
Pittsburgh Food Bank and and this is
exactly what's been in my books for
years and years and years that they were
going to and create some kind of major
incident that led to the demolition of
independent livelihood so this hunger
society would be created in a very short
time and that's what we're we're looking
at and you see if they released a virus
they really say a bio weapon some people
claim out of this Wuhan lab then you
lose control of it you don't know what
it's gonna do you it's gonna it's gonna
kill a lot of people you don't want to
kill and and people would be dead in the
streets but if you invent a virus and
you control the perception of it by
controlling the way that it is
administered and registered in death
certificates
you can decide when the numbers have
perceived they'd go up and when it
starts to fall and then and watch for
this mate
after a respite you can then have a
second and third wave and those waves
will come just before the vaccine is
ready the gates of London and we should
ask ourselves what will be in that
vaccine no David you covered 50 items I
have to go back I have to go back and
unpack some of these things here because
a lot of statements were made now and
let me go through and then you'll have
your time to respond just like I gave it
to you one you said coronavirus cover 19
is not real
that's one okay so then from there you
said that the CDC and World Health
Organization who the number two largest
funder is Bill Gates after us depending
if US pulls out then it's a different
story and you know Trump and Ted Rose
are having issues and we know Ted Rose's
very good friends with China that's
something that everybody knows the
pictures the relationship things changed
when they were part of it everyone knows
that none of that is private but if if
this was something that they wanted to
spread to make it real he would have
called it a pandemic sooner rather than
later because the criticism CDC gets and
the World Health Organization is getting
from Trump today is for not saying that
earlier that is a pandemic rather later
which is a big criticism that Trump's
giving him so let's put that aside now
as far as gates coast would vaccine and
his comments about depopulation or
reducing population growth that he made
to
doctor I think all from CNN back in 2011
February when they did that interview
fine let's just say there's an element
of reducing population growth and we can
put some weight behind that because yes
Gates is a mr. pandemic 2015 he gave a
talk at TED talk and he's projecting and
predicting TED talk fine we can give
some that credibility to that and then
but then you're taking some of the
stories and you're linking it together
to give it more credibility to
connecting the dots that loses a little
bit of credibility here's why let me say
why this is why if they're getting paid
thirty nine thousand dollars the
hospitals if a person dies from Coe at
nineteen versus the number you gave a
forty nine they die if they're if
they're diagnosed if they have the
ventilator yeah if they're diagnosed
they get thirty nine thousand dollars
and they don't they get forty nine
hundred dollars from the senator you
talked about who's also a doctor okay
let's just say that think that's the
case and let's just say in Italy all of
those people that died you know
and and they're putting it in that hey
he died from coronavirus but he had
pneumonia or other issues fine this is
the part that I don't give that part of
the story a lot of credibility is
because if all of these nurses and
doctors and people who are on the inside
that are helping out and if it's all
being fabricated and it's non-existent
100 percent someone's gonna be a
whistleblower 100 percent someone's
going to come out you know them we have
unless the point you know we should
never never underestimate the power
within an organization of being told
what to do not everybody not everybody
that's why we have whistle go onto my
website and look at the doctors that
have come out and said we are being told
to put coronavirus on the death
certificate when they've not died from
it there's some there are some
whistleblowers and there will be more
cuz there's people out back it apart
that'll gain credibility because that's
the part
but they're already enough to show that
it but you cannot say coronavirus is not
real I mean you saw the movie I just
said it what I say to you it show me the
scientific evidence that Kobe 19 exists
that it's been isolated as a particular
agent are you asking or man-made is that
what you're asking are you Alec no no
simply say no testing or a genetic code
yeah not a virus I mean I've got
statements here from medical
professionals and people like a medical
scientist in America who calls the test
a Mickey Mouse test that's not testing
for Co vid 19 that's bad
that that was said some two or three
weeks ago now more and more people are
saying well it's not testing for Kobe 19
I'll tell you another story and you can
go onto my website and put the link on
my brother will put the link below
everybody can go yeah well go to the
website and you'll see a a a video by a
New York intensive care doctor and he's
named there and and he did this video in
desperation because he was saying we
were told to get ready to treat an
infectious disease called kovat 19 he
says on the video that's not what we're
seeing we're not seeing an infectious
disease kovat 19 what we're seeing he
said um in the worst of the patients
because the vast majority have no
symptoms why because there's no virus
what he's seeing he said our lungs he's
never seen before and the only way the
lungs could have gotten to that state in
his analogies is from someone in an
aircraft at 30,000 feet which went into
depressurization and the oxygen sucked
away Oh
another analogy of is someone was
plunked on the top of Everest without
any acclimatization and by definition no
oxygen that's the state of their lungs
their lungs are suffering from oxygen
deprivation I've got you know saying all
yeah this that and the other but I will
say this and this is admitted by the way
by the telecommunications industry at 60
gigahertz 5g millimeter waves interact
with oxygen molecules in a way that
affects the oxygen an offshoot of that
at 60 gigahertz is that the human body
and blood cannot absorb oxygen and if
you're hit by 60 gigahertz those are the
lungs that you would have so it's about
looking at the evidence and seeing how
the dots connect and not getting
anything off the table and so on we
should yeah I don't mind doing that what
you saved from a level of certainty
David you put you scare a lot of people
when you say from a level of certainty I
understand there being a level of doubt
because think about it you know who lee
when language right you know leah when
lankey Lee when Liang he's the gentleman
that was the doctor the 37 year old
doctor that was a whistleblower in China
at Wuhan who came out and said this
virus could spread and this is not a
regular virus and China didn't give it
any attention and this doctor died a
couple weeks later but he is saying it's
a real virus it's something that could
really spread and then yesterday news
breaks out I don't know if you saw the
press conference with President Trump
where another source came out yesterday
Yahoo shared it Fogg shared it multiple
different platforms around the world
have shared it sources believe
coronavirus originated in Wuhan lab as
part of China's effort to compete with
the u.s. : : 19 originated Wuhan
laboratory not as a bio weapon but as a
part of China's effort to demonstrate
that its effort to identifying combat
viruses are equal to or greater than the
capabilities of United States multiple
sources who have been briefed on the
details of early actions of his
government and seen relevant materials
told by Fox News
and then obviously there was an agent
who went out and you know once he went
out and he shared it with people sources
believe that the initial transmission of
the virus was bad to human and that
patient zero
patient zero who worked at the
laboratory then went into the population
in Wuhan and then it spread and one
thing I will give credibility to is
China knows they can't fight with
America or other nations purely just as
military but they want to fight it based
on bio warfare chemical computer and
virus dissemination environmental
destruction drug trafficking that is
their game their game is maybe more
manipulation I may give more credence to
that but to say coronavirus is not real
even the people that don't respect the
Chinese government who are doctors in
China who died over killed said this is
a real thing that's the part where
sometimes when I hear that it makes when
the audience and everybody calls me
saying Pat what do you think about what
this David Icke said do you agree with
them I said there's some stuff that he
says true but some of it is
sensationalized and it scares the hell
out of people no it's not
sensationalized at all and you
sensationalized stuff if you if you
overcook the pot what I'm looking at is
evidence that's come from biologists and
come from doctors and come from
specialists around the world who are
saying this is not a lethal virus that
they are claiming it is and they've not
isolated it thus they cannot prove it
exists so if something's coming out
through government then I don't care
what they say I've spent 30 years
investigating governments and they are
invariably lying to us and want us to
believe something because it's taking us
off the scent and in terms of you know
this is a lethal virus and and and it
could spread will show me that what a
number of things
show me the number of bodies dead bodies
that relate to a lethal virus you can't
because they're not there why are they
having to fix the figures provable fact
just talk to the medical professions
the guts to come out to increase the
numbers if it's a lethal virus why would
they do that why would they have to do
that why would they have to give
incentives for people to in hospitals
thousands and thousands of dollars
incentives to diagnose copied 19 if it
was a lethal virus and it was all true
why would they and and if it is a see
that that whooaaa
hand um bio lab he's a level four that's
the highest and if it's a level four
it's dealing in absolutely lethal
bioweapons okay so something was
released from there where's all the dead
people then you know it's a you try to
look at the statements from governments
but to say does it add up the numbers do
not add up tucker carlson
um is now i saw him in the last couple
of days now starting to get it slowly
but surely the others will never get it
and he started to say hold on a minute
how lethal is this virus because the
numbers are coming down and down and
down in terms of the percentage of
people who were claimed to have died
from it even with all the manipulation
of different places and we're now now
closing in on equivalent of of flu and
this is what sunny also want to say
about how this has been done and and
maybe someone can explain this to me why
they've actually had to do this the one
of the key tools that this cult uses and
it's through its gophers to manipulates
events is computer models it's computer
models that told us that well by now
years ago the north pole would have
disappeared in the summer it hasn't and
the
is projections that have caused these
lockdowns which is caused this economic
Armageddon have been done from computer
models and they've been done through an
organization in London called Imperial
College not least a guy called professor
Neil Ferguson Ferguson and Imperial
College are funded or have funding large
funding from Bill Gates then you have
this other organization in America
called the Johns Hopkins University
medical operation which is organizing
all the assimilating orbit the numbers
which the media are constantly I'm
quoting something else I could talk
about at length and their connections
not least two people I gates um and this
Ferguson because you see when it when it
came to Britain the Prime Minister like
Trump has pushed back on it to an extent
the Prime Minister um Boris Johnson
clearly did not feel that what has
happened needed to happen and he was
asked if the professional soccer league
should stop and he saw no need for that
it was the soccer league itself that
shut the football down in this country
not Johnson Johnson said there's no need
to close the schools it's all you know
we'll deal with it and then professor
Neil Ferguson came out with computer
model projections wait for this but up
to half a million British people could
die from this virus immediately course
your step into a prime minister to be
fair this is how many could die our
projections say so and you'll be
responsible if you don't lock down the
country so immediately there was a big
backtrack and Britain was locked down
and we have like America economic
Armageddon and human Armageddon
immediately the lockdown was in place
Ferguson and Imperial College start
reeling back and say oh no probably less
than 20,000 but the half a million has
got the lockdown and computer models are
perfect because what comes out as a
projection is dictated by what goes in
as data he was the man by the way who
said that between one and two million
plus people in America could die from
this virus same guy and there's a scam
going on here there's a scam of creating
a massive manufactured problem that
devastates and destroys the world
economy and pearls billions of people
into the lower reaches of this Hunger
Games society that's what's going on and
they don't need a virus for that they
just need the perception of one so so
again so you just went to two different
places at David first you said virus is
not real then you went to Tucker Carlson
is getting it because he's saying
fact that it's not as infectious as
others are saying it is those are two
different conversations no no they're
not let me know then oh no they're
absolutely on not one of them not scored
no no no wait a minute
it's about perception um oh those are
two different statement that I have to
hold you accountable to that David you
said this to me please just let me
explain for a second it's about
perception my perception is from my
research over ever since this started
because there is no virus Tucker
Carlson's perception is that there is
and his first movement away from the
official story is that the the
infections are and the death rate of the
virus he perceives to be real is nothing
like they're telling us therefore he's
starting to question the official story
while still believing there is a virus
going much further than that
so he has a different perception of me
in terms of the fair enough
your teas cooing is moving away from the
official narrative and starting to
question it and if he goes on question
it he'll end up well I am I I don't know
my place no it'll never say so I don't
know about that part because about the
non-existent that's a complete different
conversation that's all right don't
believe it there may again
as I've said although out long in this
chair I'm not trying to get people to
believe anything I'm saying here's some
information make of it you will and by
the way let's not forget this and well
this guy in a one-bedroom flat in
England has done one interview more than
one interview interviews on on this
subject the mainstream media 24/7 in
every single country is banging our
unquestioned the official story that's
given to them by the authorities
questions just banging it out repeaters
propagandists who's there and yet
someone having a different view is
somehow outrageous and look at look at
YouTube and Vimeo and Facebook one guy
in his little flat in England does an
interview with Brian Rose on London real
and it was like someone shouted fire one
guy compared with the global media
putting out the official story why cuz
truth is far more powerful and lethal
then lies III I don't we're on the same
page with the media I don't think you're
gonna get any kind of dispute there
because I agree with that we both know
only a handful of people own a majority
of the media worldwide and we need more
fleep free platforms like YouTube but
you also know if you're married to a
woman and you got a wife you can say I
love you million times and you say that
one word once you say the wrong thing to
your wife or your spouse they're gonna
remember that one thing not a thousand
times you said I love you kids have this
issue with their parents I will never
forget when I was seven years old you
said this but I took care of the other
eleven years but that one time so you
said a lot of things that are things to
really think about but a couple things
you say kind of a takes it to a complete
different direction so let me go
different rod now still on the topic of
five G I'm curious to know what you
think about this year the CEO of five G
a huawei step down yesterday I don't
know if you heard or not the CEO of
Huawei
he stepped down yesterday ran and a new
guy was replaced named Jim to which no
one knows a lot about him and a couple
of things happen here this has to do a
little bit with you British intelligence
is now saying that UK needs to
reconsider their relationship with
Huawei and when they said this British
you're from UK stricter control of
high-tech and other industries while we
send an open letter yesterday an open
letter yesterday which you ought to read
yeah so not to change its partnership on
5g with Huawei or else it will cause
them harm now you know
this is similar happening to France as
well the differences Britain you know
you can't kind of agree to want to do
this you know I've never been too
comfortable would Huawei I've never
trusted Huawei I've never seen the the
intentions there and and my thoughts are
different than yours where you think 5g
is helping coronavirus spread which I'm
not there at all I'm more from the
standpoint of China wants to be able to
control and their motivation was to
control and gather data and one of the
ways to do it is to do this
what made it very interesting is the
following while they're negotiating with
France on these ventilators the medical
equipment that China's making for France
China has said if you want the medical
equipment you have to be willing to
install Huawei 5g in France and France
is now backing out of it so what are
some of your thoughts with what's going
on with Huawei and the 5g not from
coronavirus standpoint just purely from
Huawei 5g standpoint well first of all I
keep coming back to this but it's
important I'm not saying that 5g is
causing the coronavirus because I'm
saying there's no evidence
scientifically that there is one of
those coronavirus in a big need family
of viruses but I mean kovat 19 what I'm
saying is 5g is incredibly destructive
to the human body and the human mind
because of its frequency its frequency
power by the way just a very quick one
um the American law enforcement and the
Israeli law enforcement and it'll be the
same around the world when it gets there
use 5g frequencies to disperse crowds of
protesters because what they do they
have these trucks and they fire this
millimeter-wave IG frequency range
frequency and the skin is an antenna
this is well known by science the skin
is an antenna decodes frequencies and
what the skin does with these 5g
frequencies from these military law
enforcement trucks is they decode this
frequency they bang out
to the into a feeling that their skin is
on fire listen this is all in military
documents not speculation and thus the
people scatter because they want to get
away from the that the frequency so that
their skin doesn't feel like it's on
fire so so this is that's one frequency
part of the frequency band of Phi J the
idea when the skin and the sweat ducts
scientists have pointed out of aunt Anna
that interacts with five G frequencies
but that's not going to be damaging is
insane and one of the things that 5g
does is undermine the immune system and
and therefore will open you up to a lot
of other things but what I'm saying
about five g and this alleged virus is
that this extreme lung condition that
some people seem to be getting that is
equivalent to oxygen deficit this 60
gigahertz frequency of the five G range
would produce that that's what I'm
saying
my main point is not about 5g it's about
the fact that the virus death rate and
case rate is being manipulated by a the
test and B the the the diagnosis of
Kovac 19 for everything that moves
so I'm you know but what is happening I
talked about this this smart grid where
everything is connected to a smart web
all your domestic appliances your smart
meters eventually the human brain
connect into AI it's all connected to
this grid called the smart grid and it's
what I've been calling for decades the
technological sub reality they were in
the process of creating now they're
calling it the smart grid and we're
having smart cities and all this stuff
going on now for smart this smart grid
to function it needs at least five G
levels of communicative power and for
the smart grid to encompass the entire
planet there has to be five G
on every inch of the planet that's why
the Musk's and people are putting tens
of thousands of satellites up firing 5g
at the earth to cover the entirety of
the earth because it's part of this
technological sub reality system to be
run by the technocrats controlling the
hunger games Society and you know how
many people around the world are sitting
at home because their business is
considered non-essential and people who
go out are picked up by the police and
fine sometimes even jailed for being out
of their homes at the wrong time or in
the wrong place but what is considered
essential business and work is banging
out worldwide and the evidence for this
is overwhelming from people who've said
are on another five 5g towers are going
up around my house
somebody says it in this country in that
country in that country is overwhelming
and I I know because it's happening
around me is that while people are under
lock down house arrest and there's no
possibility at least unless people
challenge authority of protest phi g is
being rapidly rolled out all over the
western world and beyond by the end of
this they will have this 5g
communicative system with more and more
satellites going up getting closer and
closer to what they want to run this
smart grid which will include
controlling the human brain via AI
connection so whether it's Huawei or
some other company in the end as you go
back you'll find they're controlled by
the same force ultimately which is
driving in this old smart grid and what
you get I said that the cult has no
borders but it wants to maintain an
illusion of borders and an illusion of
competition
maintain the illusion that there is no
force that's behind all of it so this
this these things between China and
America and all these things yes on one
level they're happening but get to the
cult level of both countries they're
both on the same team driving the world
in the same direction and that same team
are you going back to the whole new
world order and humanity all of that
when you say the same team yeah they're
all there they're all there are names
for different aspects of the same web
yes and and different aspects of and and
specializations within the web yes
they're all connected so who would is
the most powerful family right now in
the world any names today that you would
say are the most powerful if you're
saying there's a you know somebody
behind closed doors that's moving
everything like a puppeteer who are the
most powerful people in the world well
if you look through the history of this
the the Rothschilds have been massively
massively at the heart of this so of the
Rockefellers but if you go deep deep
deep into the web to those secret
societies around the spider they won't
be on public display they won't be on
public display and therefore they're
very difficult to identify but you can
identify their outcomes their agendas as
they play out and and because there is
an agenda that can be accessed if you
work your ass off then that's why my
books have been so accurate because you
you expose the agenda you predict the
future the holy the whole point of my
life is to alert enough people of what
the agenda is and where it's going for
there to be an intervention to stop it
that's the whole point on point of what
I do
I mean you know I could do other things
with my life but I get up a 4 or 5
o'clock in the morning I work all day
til I go to bed and I did that seven
days a week because I don't I mean I'm
just coming up now you mentioned earlier
April the 29th to my 68th birthday you
know
another two years I'll be 70 this is not
about me and it's not for me what I do
I don't want to see my children and my
grandchildren living in a global
Orwellian vasista --q technocratic
controlled non democratic world I don't
want anyone else's kids and grandkids to
be living in that that's why I do what I
do and what's in it for me oh he makes
lots of money already so why don't I
live in a one-bedroom bloody flat and
have done since 2001 I'm not a material
person I want to see the world being
free from this manipulation and this
control which is getting more incessant
by the day and that's what I do what I
do and I'm saying here's some is some
information make of it what you will
because I'm not trying to convince
anybody well that's a mug's game people
have to come to their own conclusions
and not be forced and manipulated into
doing so I David have you ever read the
book Dianetics by l ron Hubbard yeah a
long time ago
yeah well I think that um while they
were on haben of course was in naval
intelligence as I recall I think the
whole Scientology thing is an aspect of
this cult I and and same with same with
some of these other religions like
Jehovah's Witnesses and stuff and
because all these groups are
compartmentalized the vast majority of
people in amel have no idea that that
they're part of this web but the core
will Nestle it works who you trust who
do you trust to be who does David Icke
trust to be I trust I trust my own
instincts my own intuition based on
factual support
I trust my family because they are have
shown themselves to be extraordinarily
loyal and genuine and I trust other
people who have shown themselves over a
period of time a considerable period of
time to be trustworthy and to care about
what they do and to be committed to it
and other than that my jury's out until
yeah until I'm dead it showed to me
otherwise
no no what Paul was impressed if I'm
gonna go to the last party and we'll
wrap up is the fact that you and your
first wife Linda were married for 29
years
and there was a scene of you guys
talking and you're still friends even
though it didn't work out you're still
friends and your relationship that said
a lot about if somebody's been with you
for 29 years and she's still even after
that well we were together married for
29 years but we're still together she's
a great friend and support lives just
down the road very interesting about a
minute walk away all these years later I
met Linda for the first time at a dance
hall when I was a professional
footballer
really young one and that would have
been in 1970 1971 we met we married
within a matter of literally a few
months with no money and she's still my
mate so you know relationships may
change their nature but love never dies
that's a whole different topic but I
just wanted to bring that up that was
impressive David I might give you names
and tell me the first word that comes to
your mind it's called speed round I'll
give you a name tell me the first thing
that comes to your mind all right
hey Ted rows on huh no I don't get that
one hedge rows he is the director of a
World Health Organization Oh Ted Ross um
gates his mouth bill gates psychopath
Elon Musk psychopath President Trump
someone who doesn't really understand
what's going on around him has certain
instincts which are pushed back by those
around him were at the controlling
events and owned 100% by Israel Morris
Jonathan bewildered allowed himself to
be bounced into this by the dark suits
ah Winston Churchill not what he
appeared to be Xi Jinping who's that xi
Jinping the leader of China
oh the present guy yes ah cult operative
to his DNA
Anthony foul to you Gates his mouthpiece
it's his melodies Andrew Kaufman genuine
man trying to do genuine things Princess
Diana died because of what she knew Alex
Jones someone who's done his best for a
long time to alert a lot of people don't
agree with everything he says don't
agree with everything he does but he's
made a contribution to a lot of people
waking up
Queen Elizabeth bloodline of the cult
and the idea that we have a head of
state chosen by bloodline in 2020 is
hysterically ludicrous Jonathan who's
that
okay that's fine John Lear read a lot of
his stuff a long time ago I think he
knows a lot about hidden technology and
all that side of things but it was back
in the 90s I register Jerry Allen Jerry
Allen near Jerry Allen Jerry Allen Oh
Gary Allen oh yeah I read his books a
long time ago and I think he had a lot
of Breyer correct things to say Richard
Hoagland Richard Hoagland yes yes he's
the space NASA man I'm not heard about
Richard for a long time and what's
happened to him but um yeah he's got
some interesting things to say doesn't
agree with all of them Jim Mars
lovely guy a good old boy who saw that
the world was not like come he was told
it was and did a lot of great work from
the Kennedy assassination onwards Steven
Greer wouldn't trust trust him to tell
me the time in a room full of clocks Wow
Bob Hope if people knew the real Bob
Hope they would be staggered involved in
mind control programs and abuse of women
Kissinger one of the most evil people
ever to have drawn breath in my lifetime
on this planet maybe like you for you
and telling us your story and spending
nearly three hours with us some of the
topics a little bit uncomfortable you
were willing to talk about it and I
appreciate you doing that and we're
gonna put the links below of everybody
that can go to your website for the
stories that you were talking about if
you could kindly send us the specific
links we'll send them there and again
appreciate you for taking time to come
in and being a guest on vitamin in a
real pleasure base it's been a real hoot
thank you very much see ya
thank you alright this interview almost
didn't happen but it happened because we
got thousands of comments and messages
from people saying Patrick can you get
him on and we were I want to hear your
thoughts by the way on what you took
away from this obviously at this point
many comments have been going on how
much of what he says do you agree with
how much of it are you neutral how much
of it do you say I just don't believe
any of that comment below and if you
enjoyed this video I have two other
videos I want you to watch us as an
interview I do with an economist that we
talked about the link with what's going
on the economy with Daniel DiMartino
booth which is an incredible video click
on this one here and that's another
video I did with somebody who lived in
China for nearly two decades
Gordon shank as a lawyer who gave a
complete different perspective on China
having said that if you haven't
subscribed to the channel please do so
thanks for watching everybody take care
bye bye
[Music]